I signed her down to breakfast thinking
all is right with the world and I get
Sun we need to talk
this is hiccup the main character and
DreamWorks Animation's How to Train Your
Dragon 2 when bringing hiccup to life in
the first dragons movie DreamWorks used
this software called
emo but making changes took time and
rendering those changes took even more
time for dragons to DreamWorks rolled
out new software called Apollo changes
are speedy and rendering happens in real
time that's the amazing thing is we've
developed a software so it's it's never
blocked in the artist is always up to
speed it's always the latest and
greatest DreamWorks is known for its
tech-savvy approach from partnering with
Netflix to its YouTube strategy in the
recent launch of dreamworks TV the wilds
animators love pushing the limits of
technology the company's aging software
wasn't keeping up with computing power
apollo was created in partnership with
Intel over a five-year span during merge
chief technology officer Lincoln Wallen
says animators are more agile and the
studio can reduce production costs we
can play all those games and we are both
in terms of the budgets for the movies
by tens of millions of dollars as well
as the quality of the movies which you
can see in How to Train Your Dragon 2
dragons 2 required 90 million hours
worth of work to be rendered that's like
running a computer for ten thousand two
hundred and seventy three years it also
required 398 terabytes of storage
equivalent to twenty five thousand seven
hundred and forty two mobile phones with
16 gigs of storage all that technology
shows up in complicated characters like
the bewilder Beast
the size of that creature on screen to
watch it play real time and my director
going can you change this yep I can do
it real quickly which is something that
I will have taken me a couple days to do
prior as for Intel its engineers walk
away from the Apollo project with a
boatload of information we can actually
take it back and understand how in our
own let's say long-term plans about how
our Zenor Xeon Phi processors get
developed we can actually make them
better and along with using Apollo on
future films DreamWorks may make the
technology available to other into
other business sectors also create
images for various purposes they also
design product in a visual way and all
of those processes really are enhanced
and sped up by apana